oh my goodness let's eat tasty has
challenged me to make a red dish using
their red pan from their cookware set in
their hashtag cook with color challenge
today i'll be making
a very popular korean street food rice
cake fish cake green onions water
gochujang soy sauce plum syrup mirin
oyster sauce sweetener i am using monk
fruit sweetener korean chili flakes
ramen powder deep lion chicken bleach
make sure all the sauce is incorporated
and then bring it to a boil add some
white cabbage about a cup or so last but
not least our ramen noodles i almost
forgot to add our hard-boiled eggs she's
done all right y'all time to take a bite
oh now i challenge you to cook with
color using
cook with color challenge and we might
feature what you made on tasty's
instagram and be sure to tune in to
tasty's cook with color live on tick
tock with inga on thursday july 21st at
4 pm pst where she'll also be making a
dish inspired by tasty cookware colors
chosen by you now to finish the rest all
by myself oh